hi every how are you pretty
good you doing good yeah yeah I'm good
good how about you y are you
good I was bored man uh talk talk talk
the other day uh I don't understand how
you allow that you bring me two minute
as long as Sam he didn't want to talk to
me and you just cut me off and how is
that possible
the the guest didn't want to didn't want
to talk to you man it look and it seemed
like it wasn't going to go anywhere
anyway so let me tell you something I
guess uh since I debate him 3 hour and
15 minutes he couldn't cope because I
expose him he's block me saying that and
block me on another few Channel and he
is I saw the debate it looked like he
won that one yeah he won according to
him because he twist everything around
to suit his agenda regardless I watch I
watched it objectively I watched it with
my own fair fair enough fair enough you
remember when uh uh when he and David
wood and uh anony Antony was around
Usman he walk around away from and he
didn't approach Usman and he used to
always own
channel hold on y cuz I can't let you
slander the brother he did approach but
when they was at the table with utman
and you can watch if you watch his video
watch usman's video you can hear what he
says under his breath in the mic wow
three guys against one that's what he
says so he's trying to play towards the
camera and the audience and Sam didn't
play into that that's why he talked to
the Muslims around yeah Sam didn't
confront him when he need to while he
was always call calling on his own
channel to challenge Osman but this is
the proof once again that he is just uh
uh uh trying to take advantage of people
who doesn't know and just to make money
out of
people just spreading
deception him when you confront him with
Channel Chanel is not monetized
bro okay uh let's get to something let's
get to something for real man you're
here now is here you guys have to bring
man Islam is false to me change your
mind Aisha Aisha H Aisha
okay isa's age you want to talk about
that yes please I don't believe that she
was 6 years old or 9 years old okay I
say why I say why first uh Aisha was
engaged to M
buj who uh canel the the marriage after
Abu Bakr her father uh accepted
Islam and one more all the children of
Abu Bakr from his two wife he have four
children they were born before
610 when the prophet peace upon Him
received the
Revelation let's say Aisha was born
605 plus five till 610 she is 5 years
old yeah the prophet peace upon him
where are you gone come back what are
you the prophet peace upon him marry her
and lived with
her
623 after the hij just to make just to
make this go quick you re you reject all
the Sunni
Hadith I'm going to give you uh the
sources I'm rely on because uh this
subject it hurt me because it's
offensive for the prophet and it great
the prophet be beside the prophet have
11 wife he would
not respect I'm not interested in all of
that I just want to know do you are
these Hadith that say that she was nine
are they wrong uh it contradicts the
Quran and the Quran gives you the
criteria of marriage the
crer okay so where yeah what do what
does the Quran say the criteria of
marriage the criteria of marriage you
can read
it and Quran M uh chapter 4 5 56 and
3021 it should be sound and and mature
and get because she marriage is a a a
partnership between men and women and
Allah subhah wa ta'ala
chapter
four
chapter the divorce chapter he talk
about women not talk about little
children and
Prophet with Excuse me the prophet would
not go against what he's uh receiving
the word of
God AA Aisha she narrated over 2,000
Hadith from the prophet a six years old
brother would not be able a 9 years old
she
one point at a time because you're using
a lot of pres presuppositions here you
said that in chapter four it's talking
about grown women this that's
what what chapter what what verse are
you talking about where it says that
that marriage be between adult women who
are Sal let let me let me explain it to
you uh chapter 4 verse number five and
test the orphan ability and receive
judgment as they reach they reach the
marriage age then if you find them
sound their wealth yes okay so regarding
who regarding who regarding the orphans
right yeah
orphan this a appical for as well
because when you have yeah it's not
different no it it's the same because uh
the criteria of marriage first uh she
should have somebody carer or parent to
allows the marriage there should be two
adult uh Muslim to witness the marriage
and there should be but if she if she's
an orphan she doesn't have any she
doesn't have any parents or anybody to
approve of anything this is why when it
talks about giving the orphan what is
theirs they have to be older and they
have to be a marriageable age sound
stuff like that that's what it's talking
about there when it's talking about
General in marriage that's a different
story if you're talking about in general
I agree and her father and her mother
were uh present so they would not uh
allow if she is underage and as I
mentioned to you was before she was
before engaged to
M but if you have when you're not
dealing with orphans the ruling is
different so when you go to chapter 4
verse what was it
uh read it for
me I just read it for you yeah 654 sorry
654 you know the
verse right where it talks about
divorce 654 uh put it
on and let's read it together before you
go put it put it on screen
chapter number five uh test the orphan
ability uh that they reach the age of
marriage why say in the age of marriage
that mean if
AAL uh you can you for everyone not
only dealing with orphans women he's
dealing with orphans because they don't
have anyone to approve of a marriage
when they're
younger this is this is another you're
absolutely right yes they have a
guardian they have a Guardian guardian
can approve of a marriage even if they
are young and no
no because as I said as I said
again
chapter
30 yeah here you are 654 it says and
those who no longer expect ministration
talking about divorcing these these
women right those who no longer expect
ministration among your women if you are
if you doubt then their period is three
months and those who have not ministr so
the same thing their period is also
three months right
wait hold on hold on hold on and no
expect ministration among you your women
he's talking about women the word the
word I heard what you're saying the word
saw applies to little girls yeah my my
dear my dear I am Arabic speaker I I am
Lebanese and I I will explain it to you
uh you among your women and there period
is three months and also for those who's
not minated that means those who not
minated from among your women not among
your
children and who have notrated by way so
yeah yeah so down for me does the word n
does the word niss also apply to young
girls
no let me show call
let me show you a vers it's all
right you know the story I know my
language okay you know the story where
um well where Pharaoh had all the
children of Israel the firstborn Sons
killed right but the Nissa were spared
right what verse is that I think it's 49
you familiar with that before we go
there let me just explain a little bit
about the same verse here because if you
I don't need no we're focusing on one
point you're to your whole point hinges
on the word women here or n the point is
you need to read and for those who are
pregnant their time until they give that
part has nothing to do with what I'm
talking about y y I need I need you to
look brother my patience is running thin
I need you to follow with me flee uh the
word n is what your point hinges on you
said it's referring to women Nissa
you're an Arabic speaker so you know so
this is what we're dealing with here
okay okay so you said that the word
Nissa only refers to mature grown women
so right here in this verse the same
word is used right here it says and
recall when we saved your forefathers
from the people of pharaoh who Afflicted
you with the worst torment slaughtering
your sons and talking about the newborn
Sons right you know the story right
it's between bracket
why I know I didn't say that in that's
in the verse I'm just asking you are you
familiar with this story uh here they
are talking about the children that far
he used to kill the children male and
female the little one
exactly but he only killed he only
killed the sons he he left the females
alive he left the female alive so they
can abuse them sex
and so so the children the baby children
were left alive right the females the
female children were left alive right no
no he is killing the
children that means the children being
killed female
andic listen listen I'm explaining to
you uh just give me uh just let me
finish my uh my sentence it's more than
obvious that mean is is Slaughter your
children says your sons slaughtering of
your sons is it's your
son is is is male and
female that mean
together boys and girls
and and they are uh like abusing your ch
why why does every top sear that I read
say that it's talking about the sons
while leaving the baby girls alive
slaughtering your newly born Sons this
is
explaining uh what has just been said
and sparing retaining your women because
of the saying of some of their priests
that a child born among the Israelites
shall bring about the end of your rule
so he killed this the boys but left the
girls alive according to jelan same
thing here with kashani um here it
is they bailed y y y namely the sons of
God's close friend Jacob right b boom
let's get to where he that is a long ha
oh here it is slaughtering your sons
namely those spiritual powers from the
speculative
rational all right he's he's he's doing
too much in his let me just get down to
imate the inoc
there of Israel hold
I show me show
me show me yeah okay when we explain to
all right order that every newborn male
among the children is of Israel be
killed and that the girls be left
alone when he
say it's not only talking about the male
it's talking about the
children it include male and female this
is
what to be honest I find it uh wrong the
explanation
because that mean all of them all your
children There's no distinction between
male and female got all right yeah thank
you I got you so so all the t is wrong
all the Quran is wrong you're right
and and when
the all the top Seer understand this
when the Quran is saying that he had
their their sons slaughtered that they
left the baby girls alive and it uses
the word Nissa women for the baby
infants all your top under understand
the same way so your Quran uses the word
n not just applying to to grown women
but also the baby infants as well you're
question the word and relying on uh
actually a weak explanation and it's not
I'm telling
you uh you ask anyone uh when if for
example I have a few children somebody
is talking to me he will tell me how is
your children he's not going to tell me
how is your only Sons without including
the girls so that mean your children
your children is included boys and
girls that mean they are taking your
women as captive and they are abusing
them and sexually so Allah subhana T
reminding the Jew that faroh he used to
uh degrade and abuse go ahead and land
your point because I'm about to move on
did you finish your
point we have something else to talk
about no I'm moving on to the next guest
bro because you're please unfortunately
we're not we're not we're
not regarding I'm gonna give
you I'm moving on move TIY move on